this is
America America don't care how you get
your money jackpot is $256
million just keep thinking about that
old
question what would you do if you had a
million
dollars wow you're a
winner
156 wow are you kidding me
give me that ticket man 156 million give
me that ticket right
now all right take it take
it
Poli hey hey it's what we going to do
turn off the
lights oh my God
156 million what's your plan I'm not
going to hold you hostage this secret
got a price tag this could be our chance
at a better
life what about the bodies this is
wrong nobody ever got rich without doing
no
crimes what was that
for they don't arrest cop killers they
execute them give us the ticket we'll
let you walk away what do you want us to
[Music]
do I need you to realize the situation
you're in
here the winner always tells the
[Music]
story back away or I will burn this
ticket
you got the power
now what you want to do about
it